that don't that don't like that think
about that
sharks all right we're here to pick up
the eMac I'm along one of 88 in the
world this is number 13 and it's on its
way into mr. Wonderful's Pen collection
at the prototype I shot that with shark
de Aquila's for the first time
wow it's way bluer and bluer than the
prototype beautiful and I have my eye on
number 13 as you can correct such an
good news I got it you got
it's gorgeous see that's a lacquering
technique and diamond on the top number
13 very controversial number that's what
I like about it oh that is gorgeous the
craftsmanship on that open it up let's
look at the nib that was another
beautiful thing I liked about it
oh isn't that gorgeous beautiful
absolutely spectacular
all right and I'm going to put some blue
ink in it too right for the first time a
lot of people will not ever write with
these pens they collect them only keep
them in this box but not me I want to
actually write with it use it live with
it and then of course I'll put it in my
coffin because I'll need it in the
afterlife
[Music]
well it's so smooth one of these days it
starts like jumping on the tank and get
a nice be nice crazy
this is a [ __ ] being set up alright
[Music]
[Music]